was j.r smith worried about what
everybody else is worried about
well where will lebron james go
i think we all have a clue
lebron's beard says take me to philly
but his hair says take us to the
clippers
that's that's not brian that's how brian
complain what's wrong guess we all don't
want to win
what
we play cards and you beat right in the
hands
i work hard every day
what
[Music]
cars i work hard every day i get up
i'm in the gym i dedicate myself what
the [__] are you talking about bro
and then there was all the talk about
how kobe
needs shaq to win a championship i mean
me personally i couldn't help but notice
how the boston celtics didn't need
either of you
kobe bryant a guy that would push me and
help me win three titles in a row
but also help me get pushed off the team
and traded to miami
draymond green stopped kicking people in
the groin and moved on to something much
worse his own podcast
it's a tough lesson
because of you i started growing my
beard all right but i noticed that as my
beard got longer i started playing less
defense did that happen to you
[Applause]
clearly dirk is a tough guy
although the most painful thing
may have been his rendition of we are
the champions
i think we should take a picture uh but
we should make it quick before one of
these guys starts yelling at mario
give him a make here is this my main
camera right here oh my god right there
[Laughter]
[Music]
lebron
you used to be a good guy
and then you turned into a bad guy
and now you're a good guy again
and you left the nba hanging what are
they going to do when they don't have a
bad guy exactly what we do they're going
to make a new one
[Applause]
go ahead shaq no i'm just saying i'm
just letting everybody know that
you know you know if you get busy he'll
get too busy it's gonna be okay cause
i'm about here doing what i gotta do you
know happy to be here happy to be here
chuck how you doing you look good you
look real good i see you i see everybody
i see you i see you i see you our
gymnastics team was so dominant that
kevin durant told me he wants to play
for them next year
[Music]
and i got to tell you i don't think
you'd start for that team kevin yeah
russell westbrook what do you think
i'm glad you brought up the motorcycle
thing because i hate that i want you to
know that you do has he gotten you on a
motorcycle hell no
you know
no no
i'm sorry the seat's not big enough yeah
like i was saying i hate the fact that
he rides motorcycles it scares me to
death because it's not safe
it's just not even with a helmet you
don't think it's good well he go his
head might he don't need no helmet for
his head
but he's the most stubborn person you
ever gonna meet in your life but i
disagree with you you know i mean you
when you think about
when you ride a motorcycle
you have to be a defensive rider you
have to be a dis defensive driver you
don't have time to talk on the phone you
have time not to eat you don't have time
enough to do a lot of things that most
people do every single day
which is more dangerous than riding a
motorcycle yeah you have to really be
focused on seeing the traffic ahead
he doesn't know about this he's never
ridden a motorcycle you never understand
what it takes to be
a winner
i'll send you a new show where you sit
in the hot tub
your body ain't that good you can just
walk around without your shirt off if
we're ever going to talk about bodies i
want you not to be the one to bring that
conversation
all right if you don't get out of here
shaped like a beanbag that got that in
we're just a couple hundred yards from
staples center which also happens to be
as close as donald sterling is allowed
to get
hey how come he didn't play in a
celebrity game this year man
you're the part of the party what
i'm in a hall of fame and celebrity
games it's over
it's over
i can't do it anymore i achieve
greatness shaq you know what that feels
like kenny i know you know what that
feels that's just
draymond green looked like donkey from
shrek
deandre jordan looks like that uncle at
a cookout that sticks his fork in your
plate
well i think that sharing is caring so
joey
goodbye blake griffin you soft ginger
hair colored lindsay lohan freckled face
two-headed [__] take you guys home
[__]
wow all caps huh maybe throwing some
lowercase next time
face it shaq you are gigantic
that suit is bigger than the one against
harvey weinstein
[Applause]
knocked down that jump shot yesterday
that was nice better than you
[Laughter]
what is that what's that thing around
the truck
[Laughter]
growing up i loved basketball but i was
never very good at it
kenny smith you can relate right
you call me
[Music]
i'm with the suns the suns haven't been
in the finals since
1993 27 years that's a whole ariana
grande
imagine me if there was no basketball
i wonder what i'd be doing
[Applause]
i am a doctor chuck i'll see you in the
back after this
i'm gonna tell you how i first learned
how to do the basketball i took a
volleyball i dunked it and then all of a
sudden i dunked a baseball and then i
ducked my mama and then that was it
oh big dunker one big dunk
okay
one new shack i'll tell you man you
hired you're hired we understand you
much better than old shackles
steph's a pretty good shooter
for those of you who watched uh the game
against uh the wizards last night he was
to use
uh slaying he was clowning
he's all jumping up and down
bradley beal looks like if usher had
someone sit on his head while he was a
[__]
thank you chris bosh talks like a white
guy named dennis
before i go to sleep i just want to say
paul george
your good sleep
your dreams
your job when you wake up
you feel good you feel pretty you know i
feel you feel pretty that's what you
said did he say feel pretty
pretty yeah
not amazing you said pretty all the
above my man all right clay okay i'm
going to go and leave this alone clay
because at this point time i don't think
you know who you are
uh
that was pretty sad what do you think
there brian have you ever felt pretty
no i never felt pretty yeah i can't say
that i can't say that i never felt
pretty it looks real good though
look like a draft pick clay i don't like
it
i like it but i don't with anderson
[Applause]
oh man that is a wrap for inside the nba
presented by kia
for kenny and charles who i know will be
here tomorrow night we need some of that
stuff zach and for shackley hope is
coming back tomorrow night
[Music]
bernie johnson